hi everybody Welcome to my talk I'll be
talking about symmetric formulas for
products of the permutations
this joint work with Benjamin Rossman
our computational model and our main
objects of study are Boolean formulas
which we will regard as unordered rooted
trees where leaves are labeled by
variables x i or negated variables not x
i and we'll regard these as the inputs
to our computation
non-leaves are labeled by and or and
we'll call these Gates
we'll be considering AC formulas so
formulas with unbounded fan in and here
I have an example of a Boolean formula
so every n variable formula computes a
Boolean function from 0 1 to the N to 0
1 in the natural way
and We Know by probabilistic arguments
that there exists Boolean functions
requiring formula size that's
exponential
but the best formulas has lower Bound
for an explicit Boolean function is not
even cubic
so it seems that proving formula size
lower balance is a difficult problem and
in our work we'll prove formula size
lower balance for a restricted class of
symmetric formulas
to study the symmetries of Boolean
functions and Boolean formulas will look
at the action of SN on functions and
formulas so first functions
this metric group I sat on an element to
lockdown Boolean functions F by simply
permuting coordinates so to get Pi of f
the function Pi of f Pi F we'll first
apply the permutation pi to the input CF
and then evaluate on those permuted
inputs
many important functions that we study
are invariant under large subgroups of
SN so for example the symmetric
functions which only depend on the
Hamming weight of their inputs are fully
SN invariant so parity majority the more
generally threshold functions are all
fully ascended variant
okay
certain graph properties are also
invariant under the action of
um permitting vertices
so in this in the context of Boolean
functions we'll regard graph properties
as functions from 0 1 to the N choose
two to zero one
and the action will be that of
the action will be induced by permuting
vertices
yeah
so functions such as connectivity
perfect matching and click are invariant
under permutations of vertices
and thus invariant under this action
so that's the action of SN on functions
but we also want to define the action of
estimate formulas and we'll do it
similarly
in that the action on the formulas will
be induced by the action on the inputs
so here I have a formula
and I'm going to let Pi act on the
formula pi is the transposition of 5 and
7 and 6 and 8 multiplied together
and I'll
take each input X
x i and send it to x Pi by so here I
said X5 to x 7 x 8 to X6 and the
important thing to notice here is that
this left sub formula is the same sub
formula whether acted on or not acted on
because remember that we we
regard our formulas as unordered rooted
trees
so this will lead us to study the gene
variant complexity of Boolean functions
where a g is some subgroup of SN
we note that a formula is Gene variant
if it's we would we say that a formula
is G invariant if it's fixed by all
elements of G
and every Gene variant formula we
observe computes a genevariant Boolean
function
so for G invariant function f we can ask
the question of one what's the smallest
formula Computing uh F and the size of
that smallest formula will denote L of f
and we can also ask what's the smallest
G invariant formula Computing f
and we'll denote the size of that
formula by LG of F and we'll observe
that L of f is always at most algae of f
because any G invariant formula for f is
also just the formula for f
and I'll note here that there are
formulas that are not invariant under uh
certain actions so for example this
formula well I have two formulas here
both of them compute the two-bit parity
function
however this first so this first one is
fixed by this Pi which transposes one
and two
the second one I've added this
artificial asymmetry
and it will not be fixed by pi because
this sub formula will get sent to the
end of X not X2 and X2
which uh and there's no isomorphism
tree isomorphism that Maps the new
formula back to the old one
so we could ask the question uh
of whether there exists specific
functions f with large gaps between
their invariant and non-invariant
complexities
in other words
do they exist functions F that can be
efficiently computed by formulas without
breaking symmetry
so this question has been asked in other
contexts one of which is the field of
descriptive complexity Theory and in
this situation it's known that there are
functions that have large gaps between
their invariant complexities and
non-invariant complexities
so this is some related work to uh
more work on Symmetry and computation
now I'll State the problem that we're
focused on which is the computational
problem of permutation matrix
multiplication
and we'll denote this as a Boolean
function pmmkn
which uh so the problem is the following
we're given M by n permutation matrices
M1 through MK and the task is to compute
the one one entry of their product
and this is a Boolean function from zero
one to K N square root to zero one
for intuition and perhaps also visual
release visualization we can re we can
think of this in terms of the action of
the group of n by n permutation matrices
under set one through n
and all of this problem is asking is
given M1 through MK
does the Matrix the permutation product
M1 through MK send one to one
in the illustration we see that one does
get sent to one so indeed M1 through MK
the one one entry of that will equal one
they're well known and conjectured
optimal uh upper bounds for pmmkn
so the upper bound is that pmmkn is
computable by formulas of size n to the
O log k
to construct these formulas we use a
natural divide and conquer approach
which is to that to compute the matrix
product M1 through MK we can first
compute the matrix product and one
through MK over two and then the matrix
product or the second half of the
matrices
so we end up with this arithmetic
expression for the one one entry
we would then observe that we're working
with permutation matrices and so we can
convert our arithmetic expression into a
logical expression by replacing the sum
with the uh or in a
and the product with an and
at this point we can apply apply
induction to these sub problems
which we'll say which have small
formulas Computing them
and quantitatively this will result in
formulas of size and the olog k
well now observe some facts about the
symmetries of pmmkn
so we observed that pm and is invariant
into the action of ascent to the K minus
1.
the action goes is this shift the
diagonal action where i1 through Pi K
minus 1 acts on M1 through MK
by sticking the pi one in between the M1
and M2 the pi 2 in between M2 and 3 and
so on
the important observation about this
action is that it preserves the matrix
product M13 MK because when we multiply
out the Octonaut matrices all the pies
will cancel with each other
we also observed that
um the dividing conquer upper bound
formulas that I described
are also invariant under SN to the K
minus 1.
so we can restate our upper bound as pmm
k n is computable by SNK minus 1 in
variant formulas of size enter the olog
k
so it's quite interesting that the
conjectured optimal upper bounds for
pmmkn actually exhibit the same symmetry
some of the same symmetries that the
problem pmmkn exhibits
in our work we prove a matching lower
Bound for symmetric SNK minus one
invariant formulas for pmmkn
so we show that SNK minus 1 and variant
formulas for p and mkn require size and
the Omega log k
and this is tied up to constants in the
exponent because the upper bound was n
to the O log k
if we relax the Restriction of S10 K
minus one invariance or we get rid of
that restriction then the general form
of our theorem would actually separate
complexity classes nc1 and log space
which is a good motivation for this work
the way we arrive at our theorem is
actually via a tight size depth
trade-off we show that smk minus one
invariant formulas for pmmkn of depth D
plus one requires size n to the Omega d
k to the one over d
and this is a tight size depth trade-off
I said that the upper bound dividing
conquer formulas of size n to the O log
K are conjecture to be optimal so we can
frame this conjecture in the following
way the conjecture says that breaking
symmetry does not help solve
pmmkn so more more formally the SNK
minus 1 invariant formulas for pmmkn are
optimal within some constant in the
exponent
and again this conjecture would separate
nc1 and log space
if verified
now I'll give a brief and rough overview
of the idea behind the proof of our
theorem
so I'll restate the theorem as follows
let G be accent to the K minus 1 and
view this as a subgroup of S K N squared
remember the skn squared permits the
interest entries of all k n by n
matrices
and then the theorem reads G invariant
formulas for pmn requires size n to the
Omega log k
to prove our theorem we actually
consider a larger group acting on inputs
this group is G Plus which is SNK times
SNK
and the action is this Left Right action
where given Lambda and rho and G Plus
the lambdas will act on the left of the
matrices and the rows will act on the
right of matrices so this is the action
of G Plus on the inputs
so Lambda for left and rho for right
foreign
to the K minus 1 G
the shifted diagonal action of G on
inputs embeds into the action of G Plus
on inputs uh
as a subgroup of G Plus so the action of
SNK minus 1 on inputs is really the
action of the following subgroup G Plus
the subgroup is given are those elements
uh such that Lambda 1 equals rho k
equals the identity and then Row one
equals Lambda 2 row two equals Lambda 3
and so on so the action of G
by the shifted diagonal is really the
action of that subgroup under the Left
Right action
and this is that embedding
then we construct a complexity measure
on the subgroups of G Plus so for
arbitrary subgroups H we study the
complexity of constructing H as the G
Plus stabilizer of a depth key formula
and we do this by induction on the deal
so you have some subgroup page and you
you're interested in constructing a
depth D formula whose G Plus stabilizer
is H
and I can tell you
how big your formula needs to be a lower
bound on the formula size you need
so for example the unshipped diagonal
subgroup which is
consists of those elements such that
Lambda one equals rho one Lambda 2
equals row two
is constructable as the stabilizer of a
small formula so under our complexity
measure
that unshifted diagonal subgroup has low
complexity
however the shifted diagonal subgroup
will show has a large complexity
and will also show that that implies
that the diagonal subgroup
requires large formulas
so we'll actually focus on the subgroup
A and K times A and K of G Plus
called it a n is the alternating group
it's a group of S7
and the reason why we focus on a n
rather than SN is because a n is a
non-abelian simple group when n is at
least five
and because of this horizontal which
characterizes direct products of of
subgroups of direct products of groups
um will give a useful character
characterization of the low index
subgroups of A and K times A and K
so then the question is well why do we
care about low index subgroups
the answer is that we provide a
connection between the index of
subgroups and size of invariant formulas
via applications of the orbit stabilizer
theorem
so to use the orbit stabilizer theorem
we need some kind of group acting on a
set
and to construct this group action we'll
consider some formula f and we'll let s
be its A and K times A and K stabilizer
then we'll let F act on the set of sub
formulas of f
because
f is stabilized by S it's invariant
under s this will induce the permutation
action a well-defined one on the sub
formulas so this is a well-defined
rebaction
now we know that the size of f is at
least the size
of the S orbit of any f i
and by the orbit stabilize your theorem
this is equal to the index of the S
stabilizer of fi and S
so here's a connection between index of
subgroups and size of invariant formulas
and so roughly we'll have two cases
the first this index of the S stabilizer
of fi and S is large then we already
have some good lower bound on the sides
of F and we can say we're done
otherwise we roughly have that this
index is small so the stabilizer of f i
a small index in s
in this case gorzazi limo will give a
useful characterization of low index
subgroups of a n to the K times a into
the K there's roughly some relationship
between a direct product powers of a n
and S
and we'll be able to say something about
the size of fi we'll be able to say that
fi itself
must be somewhat large
and in that case
the size of f i lower bounding the size
of F5 will then again give us a good
lower bound on the size of f
so we have some connection between index
of subgroups and
variant formula size
under using orbit stabilizer theorem and
then we'll
the
part of our proof is to use this
characterization of the low index
subgroups to
um
to construct some kind of complexity
measure on the set of subgroups of G
Plus
quantitatively this will give us a tight
lower lower bound of n to the Omega log
k
so that's it uh thanks for listening and
I hope you enjoyed the talk